I think all the money's on Strickland
and you never seen a bookie with a
part-time job that scares me right there
what do you think brenon CH Strickland
via decision I think it really depends
entirely on what happens once they Clash
if dreis can get him down if he can get
a hold of him that guy is [__]
massive I think if and he manhandles
people on the ground I think if
Strickland can avoid get knocked out
early in these rounds the first and
second go and it goes to the third it's
strickling all [__] day we're going
to find out son here we go great [__]
here we go
String's so upright man so upright and
just so comfortably Spar so much man I
think that's a factor I mean I don't
know if it's the best for longevity but
that guy spars so much his his distance
control is so
good know for everybody's different a
couple years ago we had to talk about uh
Lawler that those last couple years he
wasn't even sparring anymore he was just
hitting the mid Max H Max yeah I mean
it's different for everybody but for
Shawn Shawn is all about sparring but D
police is different cuz if if Shawn
makes a mistake it's over he hit so
[__] hard and he Creek yeah but I
mean Sean's hard to hit clean man and
we're seen it right away like the the
the style he's establishing his style
right away good distance control nice
front kicks to the body Dr is is [__]
if he's going to fight off his back foot
yeah I mean and he's getting he's eating
those Jabs he's [__] if the game
plan's this stricking all day he's so
good at switching things up too man when
drus commits F see see what I'm saying
when he goes but look strong just moves
away from
it and he complement his his boxing with
those front kicks I like that yeah those
front kicks are legit that teep off the
front leg specifically a lot of that's
with training with Alex Pier he's real
good at setting things up with that te
and it keeps you away too and if you
square up with them it's it's a great
Target I it is I love Strickland's jab
too man he's good at everything man and
he's good at avoiding [__] except that
Paya left hook obviously he just needs
to avoid dup's Power Shot he's funny too
man you see that picture he took with
paja he put his right hand up he says I
have PTSD I always keep my right hand up
with a Mor P
hilarious looks good so far dude his
jab dra is is trying to find the
range once drias goes though man it is
scary very interesting though right now
sha is dictating the
pace yeah if drias lets him dictate the
pace a long night for
him oh good kick to the body there by
dup hard left kick that was a hard left
kick and coming off that Southpaw stance
lot of power in that that'll take away a
lot of the movement if you can land that
more
often there it is getting went high that
time oh he tried to sneak it in
look like he was almost there look
close I would I would tell him to
[__] invest in the body a little bit
more MH especially how tall Strickland
is especially since he already landed it
yeah it definitely affected Sean oh good
right
hand d's eyes a little red already he he
keeps that that Ki front kick keeps you
from setting up mhm
oh Sean's defense is so [__] being
good slippery bro super slippery that
was a good low kick
mhm he needs more of that he needs some
low kicks he needs to slow down some of
this and hinder some of this movement a
little bit you always have to remember
Shawn only has like one knee that's
right one quad just all [__] up he
like lost powder of his quad the
motorcycle accident dude's still out
there riding bikes you know Sean train
trained with us at rain with me and CH
sonen yeah yeah oh there's a shot there
good shot too real good he's
in good shot let see what's happening
here we I haven't seen Sean down here in
a hot
second Sean's right back
up
interesting win you the round
interesting
ah got him down again back up again oh
Sean's
up you wouldn't give off that nope I'd
give it to Sean yeah no no that's uh
that's I mean that's good it's
definitely better than nothing agree
better than sitting on the outside
getting picked apart and Sean just
cracked him with a jab again but as
these rounds go on that's going to get
tougher and tougher depends on what
impression is made the next 40 seconds
right because if dupy starts turning it
up and starts catching him with some
[__] and if Sean's worried about the
take down doesn't seem like he is nope
this round looks like Sean Strickland's
yeah take down wasn't strong enough no
and it he didn't hold down and he didn't
do any damage oh I mean it does count
for something but not that counts for
something but Sean Sean is doesn't
overshadow what strickle is doing on the
feet those Jabs are just taken over that
the front kicks to the body that's
probably why he shot in cuz he can't he
can't oh good right hand oh there he
goes one round strickling it's time for
the sniffing salts let's do it let's go
Jo get back
in round two round two let's go round
four you know what I feel listening to
the the theme song from blade when you
snort this it just goes oh the
beginning wow look was going in there
that's crazy how you know your nose been
through some [__] dude your nose has
been through some [__] going my eyes I
don't know how you can do that dog it'll
burn your ass I'm from [__] Jersey
I've been snorting bad ass since I was a
[__] going you know what I'm saying
[__] Hudson River my own
[Music]
fart oh
[__] there you
[Music]
go round two round two here we
go
[Music]
thank you brother time oh wow what a
time that's the kind of music you butt
[__]
[Music]
too with a B with a turkey basa that was
one of the greatest scenes of any movie
that's a great scene that scene's
amazing that's the scene when they're in
the club and the Blood start the
vampires start coming out yeah yeah the
the the Blood starts coming out of Tracy
[__] Lords yep Tracy Lords and
then when they look up it's day Walker
the daywalker
Walker what a [__] scene is it Ron
Pearlman in that too that the first one
no the other guy Chris
kristoferson and um who's the other guy
the white dude yeah that dude's been in
everything in everything in the
beginning he's getting his dick sucked
in the club what blade is this first one
oh go second one look at this what oh
spinning back
fist D police he's pulling out all the
false memories of uh blade there was no
buttt [__] going bro Strickland's
picking him apart here walk in the guy's
getting his [__] whistle check this
out man Strickland is picking this dude
apart
MH I'm telling if the police don't have
success in these first two rounds
exactly as he starts getting tired cuz
Strickland is not going to get like Tony
Ferguson back in the day it's a wave he
gets stronger and stronger maybe even
better dude I'm saying he slipped he
slipped on the ground happened no it's
the uh the the the [__] logos man
sometimes those logos get wet they get
real slippery yeah sometimes Jamie [__]
from over here is the cap on it is cap
on it yeah caps on yeah it's rough dude
it's good time Jamie bro I'm watching I
can see 2020 now yeah for me too fuing I
can on the floor now I can see through
the wall I'll do [__] algebra right
now dupy just landed a right
hand but if he fights like this this is
Strickland's fight all day this is his
kind of fight too and start pouring it
on too hard to deal with man so hard to
deal with how goody is at avoiding shots
you just whiffing all the time you know
how tired you get just whiffing in air
all the time and this dude just keeps
popping you and you have to explode
every time because you're trying to get
him you could try to move even faster to
try to figure out his time look what
he's doing every time he's throwing he's
like throwing with everything he's
sprinting to try to get to him and
Sean's just slipping out of the way and
then popping him with the jab yeah he
stepp the left and hit him with the jab
low Kick's huge I think he needs a lot
more low kicks if I was in his Corner
I'd be said you got to stop some of this
[__] movement and take that guy's
legs away and those are the things he is
landing he is landing the leg kicks
that's about the only thing he's Landing
I would say stop with all that other
stuff and use those punches to set up
your low kicks man because that's
something he's having success with he's
whiffing with the punches but he's
getting close enough of those punches
where he can land low kicks and he's
landed low kicks I wonder if he's going
to try and grapple more just put those
low kicks behind some Fain throw some
[__] punches to close the don't try
to even land the punch throw the punch
to get to the kick and then work on the
kicks in later rounds cuz he keeps
whiffing way off yeah oh that was good
right hand of the body that's what you
said earlier yeah that was good right
hand of the body yeah dig to that body
with that left kick too now he's s
fighting Orthodox he switched it back up
now he's Southpaw again but Southpaw use
that Stutter Step get in and throw that
kick to the
body but on the outside like this as a b
like even that he's pulling away see how
he's pulling away from the kick it's cuz
he got him checked a bunch of times he
doesn't like
it so he knows when it's not quite there
and so he's pulling there's a good kick
to the body there it
is but he's not committing to that low
kick you take a look at his shins I want
to see what his shins look like he is
not Landing those hooks is he no his
shins might be beat up I bet adisan is
killing himself right now cuz this is
this is adna's kind of fighter you
knowre this is a like for adna I mean
this is his kind of firea would eat
dup's lunch well except for this I
another take down yeah except for
this that left hook that he did land
opened up a cut on Strickland stand
right
up yeah he's not doing anything with
this yet though strickling get back to
his feet
here oh he switched oh he switched it
right back up nicely done by Sha nicely
done nicely done great
job so I mean that's something but it
doesn't make up for the fact you're
getting tuned up for the most of the
round yeah he's not doing much with the
takedowns no he's not being able to do
anything in ter terms of control and no
damage at all no hitting they really
don't give you points with those you get
something you get something but it's not
not not going to win you the round it's
not to make up for all these times that
Sean's like jabbing him in the face and
front kicking his
body there it is again there's that job
Sean's up two z d polies can't figure
him out and he's getting tired he's
getting frustrated we might have a judge
or two that's giving uh duplic around
for the take they're Canadian they're
communist who knows faar Point who knows
what kind of oh dupy's left eye is
[__]
up his left eye is a mess man it's
almost
closed it looks real bad wish they' move
that [__] thing they're going to Loop
well they're going to keep it on as much
as they can they trying to push that
[__] off but it's pretty bad dude his
eyes [__] up let's see oh his eyes
[__] up it's
bad and it's a third round only mhm and
Sean's just getting warmed up and that
cut that uh Sean has is only the outside
look at Sean that's not a bad place for
a cut it's going to drip off the side of
your face mostly Sean have his mouth
piece in yeah Sean has a very thin
mouthpiece I was watching a YouTube
video about his mouthpiece he gets a
mouthpiece it's like a tiny very thin
mouth not like everybody else's he just
wants so he could breathe good out of it
he doesn't care if he [__] his teeth up
good for him he has like a minimalist
mouthpiece I mean it's got to help your
cardio a little bit for
sure especially if your guy doesn't get
hit a
lot that jab is money dude it's
money
the jab the shoulder roll he's so good
oh look the [__] Adam Adam Martin gave
it 10 everyone's G eron bronze 1092 plus
C wow okay what are we seeing something
different they're just counting that off
the [__] takedown they don't they
don't understand they they're
incorrect I believe I agree I have it
two zero strictly yeah I do too it just
seems like he's just more effective so
obvious St
too and look at dupy's face just cuz you
get those take Downs in if you don't do
anything with it that doesn't count that
much they need that's a good low kick
that's what he needs more of that more
of that with the low kick that low kick
was
money you mean stck stck punches are
crisp compared to this guy this guy's
throwing but dupy keeps Landing low
kicks and Strickland's a human B he he
will take a guy's legs out if you keep
chopping at it it's weird strick is not
checking those low kicks like you did
against Izzy well he checked a few and I
think that's why dupy was pulling out of
some of them that left eye of dupy
something to be yeah it's bad it's bad
and it's only going to get
[Music]
worse
St is just so accustomed to sparring
it's really interesting like his
distance and timing are so goddamn good
because he Spar so much it really makes
you want like what is the right way to
train is it just Spar all the time I
that can't be the right way it's Spar
and drill it's both it's both but godamn
the sparring seems to be very important
for a guy like Strickland who just is so
good at distance match by
case he also I think strickling Spar so
much cuz he doesn't get hit his defense
so good but the rest of the guys usually
don't have his defense that's true so if
you're getting [__] up in the training
room you're screwed when he get in there
but it's also his cardio is based on the
fact that he's always sparring yeah you
know and his defense he's sparring so
much he's just so used to that [__]
coming to his head exactly exactly it's
not like that harrowing as like it is
with some people God Poli keeps trying
to throw that spinning backfist it's
just
not I know stop for [__]
sakes
Sean's just jabbing him he's basically
winning this fight with a jab that's a
big part of what he's doing dupy just
he's coming at him though man I'll tell
you he's swinging good left hook by that
opened up the
cut cracked him again now his nose is
bleeding yeah he's busting him up
man here in the
third caught him with the jab again he
just you can only take so many of those
[__] Jabs and if he's doing this to
you over five rounds your face is going
to be hamburger meat by the fourth and
fifth tell you what I'm impressed by
dup's cardio at least we're here at the
end of the third I thought he' melted by
now he's an animal man the dude's an
animal he really is he's trying with the
hands all the way up now he mean he
keeps just like waiting in and winging
him you know that's what he's trying to
do he's just kind of frustrated that
he's not hitting him try stepping
spinning back kick oh
get
oh oh dupy keeps swinging though I'll
tell you that he's not out of this no he
hits too
hard Sean just sticking behind the jab
being
smart that [__] he just knows when he's
coming and he just slides just out of
the way his spinning [__] is ter well
it's you know he's just trying ter
trying [__] terrible I love that word
me
too I would like to see the jab count
it's CRA it's got to be crazy right now
yeah cuz they're not count that
significant
strikes Sean looks like he's slowing
down a
little total strikes is 78 to 55 for
Sean yeah yeah I thought be bigger than
that well DC is throwing a lot you know
it's just not all of it's connecting but
Shan are definitely connect oh good left
hook Sean's are definitely connecting
more significantly I I have it three
nothing Strickland yeah I do too that
left hook at the at the buzzer the very
least two to one if you're [__]
communist I I don't see him getting that
round just for the take down I agree I
like that he's aggressive but you got to
give credit to the guy who's winning the
exchanges also they score fights off
damage done look at his [__] face
look at Sean
yeah is his nose bleeding no no he's got
a little scratch Nick saying pick pick
the pace up I agree pick the pace up
melt this dude melt this South African
look at his face man he's breathing
heavy El elon's watching going for a
South African brother I don't know
probably not buto he looks beat up
man that eye is
[__] that eye is is going to really
impact those punches coming from that
side too anything come from that he's
lucky stricklin on a
kicker just said someone said St they
were suggest dupes Corner was suggesting
this trickin is fatigued they must not
have watched a fight before well I think
he was slowing down a little in that
round I mean just dealing with dreas is
an animal man he's constantly coming at
you even if you're moving away from a
lot of it this is a heavy pace you're
fighting at I mean draus is he's not
being as successful as Shawn but God
damn he's forcing a lot of exchanges I
mean what the [__] DDP takes the third
who said that everyone look D Poli is
2928 what who are these people people
I'm looking at online we give them the
second round who are these people look
look Adam Martin Adam Martin has to have
some stock in South Africa or something
I don't know's out his [__] mind
let's just let's just watch the fight oh
he's bleeding yeah he's got a cut on the
right eyee now or the left eye
rather oh he's he's he doesn't like that
left eye it's bothering
him oh good right hand good punch damn
they're going to start throwing down
yep there's that kick to the body again
I like that kick to the
body I mean that's the thing he's been
able to hit him with more often than
anything that eyes of oh good punch that
eyes trouble for
Strickland well the eyes trouble for
both of them they're both up [__] up
eyes now saying from a judge's
standpoint oh it's a lot of blood yeah
cuz it looks worse and the judges see
that got hit with a big right hand
uhhuh damn yeah he's he's uh slowing
down a little Sean's slowing down a
little I think it's but again this is
the fourth [__] round
man there's a good low kick by cardio's
impressive yeah I think the the knock on
him with no cardio is gone well I mean
he's been constantly attacking to dude
he's non [__]
stop
oh damn Sean's like looping those
punches they're not coming that straight
anymore he's clinching now that's
interesting oh [__] big take down a bad
idea for stricking terrible idea put
right back up again Strickland Los in
this round he's watching wiping his eye
too not ideal for Strickland but I would
still have him up 3-1 fre he's free
a lot of damage this round though I mean
I don't know who landed more but I know
dupy put it on a little bit I think D
big right hand by dupy damn that's a lot
of blood dog dup is having some success
on the feet now that was a big right
hand yeah
was another right hand [__] come on Sean
get out the [__] way dog D pis is
coming on yeah big time Big Time this is
his round for sure
yeah
bro he's a Marauder that dude never
stops coming take down again look at
that yeah he got this round yeah hey hey
real quick you don't think Bo nickel
beats the [__] out of both these guys
yeah I think B nickel's GNA [__]
everybody up they're they're just they
they have them at the gates UFC knows
this like all right just let's figure
out these other guys just calm
down yeah how are they going to deal
with that wrestling bro how [__] luck
to all the middleweights out there b
about to murder these fools and also
like how's he so good at striking so
quick and it's just as filthy too
yeah dupy cardio is not a [__] issue
anymore not at all man dude's an animal
throwing Shawn around like this in the
fourth Sean better do some soul search
in the fifth here he's free he's got
he's got to know he's down here see this
is where those those takedowns that
don't do [__] count yes you know I mean
when he's also winning stand up too
that's like a a deal sealer right deal
sealer yeah cuz the judges go he
definitely won that one and if he wins
the next one like this [__] who wins the
next round is get dicey yeah like cu the
next round it's like a tossup like who
the [__] knows who espe if they gave the
second to dupes so you'd have it 22
going to the fifth because those first
three rounds I would give to Strickland
but they the Jud they weren't like super
dominant you can see how they give the
second yeah there could be a couple
judges going the other way I think we're
going the fourth tied four4 or 22 he
looks like vandelay in that picture bro
dupy just never stops oh dupy never
stops coming dude he's out cardio in the
the cardio King right now it's
impressive that nose job [__]
worked damn impressive Sean doesn't seem
to have the same passion as usually does
I think he's getting beat up [__]
usually you got to think about how hard
this fight is this fight is [__] hard
man for sure this fight's hard I mean
that dude never stops coming at you and
he's feeling it now which is very rare
for sea to get tired in a fight Sean's
never tired yeah you never really see
him breathe this
hard I think it's 22 look at this there
Boom the
cut
boom that was a like a rich hand that's
this was a bad IDE for Sean to engage in
this game I don't think he knew what to
do Chicago Rich hand Charlie
Murphy Oh man easily 22 22 could be damn
South Africa it could be 3-1 but it
could be
22 I'm air on the side of C I think 22
well so many other people online seem to
say it's 10 with they were 109 duplic
they could be right I feel like we know
more than they do we probably know more
than a lot of them do but it's a close
[__] fight and that round was dupy
come on Sean he don't seem into it oh
he's into it dude he's in a tough fight
man dupy is a [__] beast look what he
did to Robert Whitaker Man true the
guy's a
beast Sean's got to control this round
though this is big yeah I think that
fight could and dup's got to really turn
it up both if he wants to yeah if he
wants to win the title you got to really
do something in this round cuz it could
be anywhere in the judge's
scorecards it's a a very good fight now
I agree with you Eddie though they
should go like the Japanese style of
scoring who's winning on the end of the
fight is it's more
important I mean if you're watching a
fight on the street and a guy won in the
beginning was getting [__] up at the
end when the cops came you think that
guy won the fight Kevin o oy got it I'm
also seeing people saying Strickland's
cut looks really bad I can't see it from
my angle yeah really deep
cut I'm sure it is I mean it's bleeding
bad it bothers the [__] out of him
obviously it's getting in his eye too
unlike the one on the right eye the left
one is in a terrible
spot it's oh my God it's bleeding bad
now look at that 99
shots sh just can't get taken down this
well it's just dup's got such a
difficult style man and he's so tough I
mean to have this guy here in the fifth
round whiffing all those punches in the
first couple and then finding a home for
him in the fifth still got the grit
still in the kind of shape that he's at
to throw the kind of full power shots
the way he throws him that's most of his
shots are these full power blasts that
he throws he's trying to take your
[__] head off look at that everything
he does he's trying to take your head
off Sean should be very very careful the
take down right now agree that's when
it's coming yeah he's going to shoot
soon yeah I think the fight's predicate
on this round come on SE yeah this is
kind of it right I think so Sean land
the right hand it's a tough [__]
round to score so far well so far Sean's
winning he's more active he's he well
he's Landing more he's Landing more but
draus keeps coming at of man I mean all
it takes is one of these [__] to land
oh there's the shot there's the shot
stop shot in stuffed
it this a good fight [__] yeah is great
match
up draus is just so un imagine getting
someone to
prepare tell you what I'd like to see H
up fight one of these gentlemen I know
right but imagine getting to see like
someone try to imitate trius in Camp
like how possible how do you even do it
Sean too yeah both of them it's a weird
style to bring in
they're both awkward as
[__] boy he keeps swinging Haymakers his
cardio is nut his coach was in line that
nose was 5% Haymakers everything's
Haymakers like the guy doesn't yeah he
doesn't try to touch you with nothing no
he doesn't set anything
up minute
30 o got to do something virtually no
Jiu-Jitsu in this match you know what
I'm talking about stuffed it again stuff
take down again didn't have opportunity
either oh D hit Dre hit him right on
that eye did he yeah he hit him right on
that [__] up eye and stung
him damn good low kick good body kick
those are all still got power man
still got
power deep into the
fifth still though I'm giving this round
to Shawn definitely more active Sean's
whiffing too here he's tired man he's
tired this is the fifth round of a
[__]
War get going Sean come on
Bud there you go but he's throwing his
arms like they weigh 1,000 lbs you see
the difference he's weighing it but
they're they're like his arms are tired
yeah everything's ex oh right hand over
the top his arms are exhausted man oh oh
he's picking it up oh he's picking it up
yeah Sean how about you want a big dog
let's picking it
up you better be careful playing this
game
with bro he's throwing kicks and
everything exed score this round scor it
to that round SE Sean 3-2 100% that's me
being cool 3-2
yeah wow what a fight what a
fight what a
fight boy just tell you what man when
lose a draw D is dupy is a monster great
F and he's only going to get better
after that fight y I mean that's the
first time he's ever been really tested
inside the Octagon like that a lot of
punches he did but still made it crazy I
mean the dude's a bull Bo nickl about to
twist both of dates off you know what
I'm saying when do they let this could
be a [__]
draw they give him Bo nickel like he's
not even a ranked guy he's on the main
card when is he going to get to a ranked
guy well I think the UFC knows he going
to be champ like let's let's let the it
clear up and then we're going to release
the hounds especially when you uh when I
had him on the podcast he said he's only
been striking for two years crazy it's
crazy I just had him on my podcast too
looks great isn't he the best the best
he has it all check check check check
checks all boxes yeah he's the Tim Teo
[__]
UFC I just don't see how they give dupes
that fifth round well not the fifth
round no not the fifth round but it all
depends on whether or not we saw those
other rounds the same way the judges saw
them that was the fifth they also might
take credit the take Downs bigger
yeah they
might that was the one that was the one
that really [__] up his
eye who knows let's see throw me one of
those mints Papa you ready for another
one let's go let's [__] go Joe thank
you brother let's [__]
go this one of your sponsors no black
Buffalo black oh black Buffalo
that stuff's good yeah I love
it what do you all let's see if these
judges [__] it up but I I have Sean
32 yeah let's hear it crank it
up yeah I think Izzy's watching us going
come on I know right Izzy's thinking
what he could have done yep a prime Izzy
come on bro well Iz he that's not
injured is he that realizes that Sean's
a lot better than he thought is over
Focus uufc
300 let's [__]
go oh boy split
split oh
[__] 48 47 for the winner by SP
decision
wow never seen a bookie with a part-time
job my
friend
wow
interesting I think me and Drake jinxed
stri yeah he's the kiss of [__] death
very
interesting I wonder how the people
online feel about that because you know
we're not scoring it while we're
watching it we're watching it we're just
having
fun were we
wrong man we watched this more one it
was close man it was good and you got
three these Jud you know what I mean you
don't know who these judges are listen
fourth round he did
awesome wow I think IO Bo nickel eats
these guys
lunch interesting bro how about him
versus
Hamot it's shot 185 or 170 70 70 how
about him versus Hamza UFC 300 Ramadan
ooh that's true [__] I know right well
Hamza fighting Ramadan he's crazy
absolutely not no nope won't do it no
says he won't do is that one is that I
think it's all of April right y they
would be fighting during Ramadan yeah
but can't you just sleep all day and
then eat at night yeah can't you do that
at night can you just adjust your sleep
tough like like makev said absolutely
not but I know that uh bala's done camps
through
Ramadan
yes
wow um Jamie what do the people online
think that's what I was saying before a
lot of the uh like drias early early
rounds dcus they gave the early rounds
to drias commentary was a lot towards
stus
really I'm just reading like the hash
UFC 297 feed though it's just flying by
so I'm just sort of trying to
interesting they're going crazy in South
Africa Strickland got cheated Strickland
won close who Rand random people what
about um check Donald Trump
[Laughter]
Jr how about Luke Thomas Luke Thomas
says good first round oh this is 26
minutes ago
she said before it says uh this one's
going to be close I can see 4847 either
direction as close on paper as we
imagined so he said the last two rounds
I definitely think he won the fourth but
you think he won the fifth I don't know
man the fifth seemed like it was was
Landing more shots whiffing a lot look
at the Cy strike numbers too Sean landed
a [__] ton more
punches look at this
here so total strikes 154 to 18
116 um take down zero he got six sub
attempts no one got any uh significant
strikes 143 for Shawn versus 114 for
tus the thing about that though is like
a lot of them might have been in the
early rounds just give them a 10- n
round for those significant strikes so
it's not it's not necessarily if you see
like a big number like that it doesn't
necessarily mean that the guy won the
fight no if you're doing it the right
way interesting tough fight though close
F listen if Izzy wants to come back and
he wants to fight draus